[Musique]
moi même en a parlé mais on se rappelle
aussi probables étaient partis avant on
était un château et années à venir la
marine elle accroche le bateau et faire
chier quoi bien dit votre nom devant des
professionnels vous rendez m'en sers
profession ces volets battants par des
professionnels
il quitte à nous à faire ce métier pas
du coup et vous êtes comme moi c'est
aussi la profession moi aussi la parole
des indiens profession dernier et de
malte et robert options possibles on
n'est pas là ces gens autour de vous les
connaissez bien 90
cagnina voilà que je marchais elles ont
poussé etienne
vous approuvez de votre profession
depuis 150 ans les gestes sont les mêmes
on a chargé le faudra d'abord les corps
gras des huiles animales ou végétales
la soude caustique et y attaquent ces
l'empaquetage première phase de la
saponification
hélas il est passé sur ekobo ça et je
suis les réserves en eau libre
comme on était tous à vos liés sur la
fin on était logir la savonnerie ou à
travailler et
j'ai commis ici à m'amuser avec un
morceau d'os travail sur les chariots à
l'aller les mises
la grande idée cette amibe yayi alors je
suis connu comme tout le monde et je
passais la certificat d'études il
croyait d'être arrivé à votre méthode
maréchal parce que malgré cas quand même
pas une tendance à vouloir jouer et il y
avait quand même un métier qu'il
m'appelait savez
ça va
les savanes premier à aller à laval où
ses rivaux
ensuite le relargage on met du sel dans
le gâteau le but faire descendre les
piscines au fond du chaudron et là
dessus c'est déjà du savon troisième
phase la cuisson on va rajouter encore
de la soude
on a laisser bouillir une douzaine
d'heures température 120 degrés
wayne robert quatrième phase c'est là
que tout va se jouer que vont s'exprimer
pleinement le talent il secret du maître
savonnier va rechercher l'équilibré du
savon par deux minutieuse opération au
fil des heures
[Applaudissements]
entre ce salon qui coule et la minute où
l'huile a été précipité dans nos fonds
il s'est passé six jours et le savon est
né
papa de la championne
mon grand père est mort mon père a pris
sa place à d'ailleurs que le métier
saoudien n'a pas savouré
malheureusement l'évolution était là et
j'ai pas dû exploiter mon métier comme
tête à ma famille avait fait pas ce que
vivent souvent en disparaissant fête
s'est terminée il ya les cheveux comme
le sort sera pas mon fils qui j'apprends
le métier ça c'est impensable
à dix mètres des chaudrons de robert
valentin derrière une porte des machines
des machines dont toutes les opérations
sont continus et qui font dans quelques
heures un savon que les maître savonnier
mettait six jours à calais c'est le
royaume des mécaniques on ne goûte plus
le savon on analyse en laboratoire
ce sont des ingénieurs chimistes qui se
charge de l'opération
des générations de ménagère au fait
sécher leurs savon de marseille sur leur
cheminée c'est désormais inutile la
dessiccation est pratiquement
instantanée dans le procédé continue
je
c'est pas possible que ça serait père
commissaire aux comptes devraient à
peine ce qui va pas de main nouvel essor
en voyez vous les jeunes tôt ou tard
prendre conscience que le savon de
marseille par sa qualité de pure beauté
naturelle est tout simplement
irremplaçable
en tout cas au nom de tous les malades
et et par reconnaissance et bien c'est
ce qu'on lui souhaite
[Musique]